نقص الادويه في العراق لا يقتصروا على نوع
محدد فالمستشفيات والحكوميه عاجزه عن
توفير قائمه طويله على راسها ادويه مرضى
السرطان الذين باتوه مجبرين للبحث عنها في
السوق السوداء للحصول عليها باسعار باهظه
جدا
بايش الادويه من بره غاليه ب 50 وب 40 و
60 و100 واحنا احنا ناس ما عدنا القطاع
الخاص
80% من سوق العقاقير الطبيه في العراق
والتي يدخل معظمها الى داخل البلاد بطرق
غير قانونيه
هذا الاحتكار ادى الى وفاه العشرات يوميا
في المستشفيات
بسبب ارتفاع اسعار هذه العقاقير ومع الاسف
على حكومه اللي عدم المتابعه للصيدليات
وازيد الناس تعبانه
والمستشفيات عدم توفر الدواء بيها
فالمواطن وين يطر يروح يطري يروح علما
للخاص رغم حملات التفتيش التي نفذتها
وزاره الصحه والاجهزه الامنيه لعدد من
مداخر الادويه والصيدليات التي تحتقر بعض
العقاقير الطبيه الضروريه الا ان ذلك لم
يوفر حلا لهذه المشكله ولم يوفر الدواء
لمحتاجين من بغداد منتظر الرشيد العربيه